merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur bernard perrut
monsieur le premier ministre
les rapports de la cour des comptes se
suivent et malheureusement se
ressemblent mais depuis cinq ans vous ne
respectez pas ses avis éclairés et le
résultat est accablant
non seulement nos comptes publics ne se
porte pas mieux la fin de votre
quinquennat mais surtout vous allez
laisser tous les voyants au rouge pour
au successeur
le rapport annuel de la cour rendue
publique ce matin et sans détour et
adresse un jugement sévère à votre bilan
puisque l'objectif de déficit en dessous
de 3% du pib pour 2017 sera je cite très
difficile à atteindre
conséquence les économies promises ne
seront pas atteintes des risques
importants de dépassement pèsent sur
d'autres dépenses et la cour cite les
dépenses d'assurance maladie et les
tours de passe-passe du gouvernement
pour boucler son budget et que penser
chers collègues de la masse salariale de
l'état qui augmentait de 3 % en 2017
c'est à dire autant qu'entre 8 2011 et
chers collègues d'un côté des dépenses
sous-estimé de l'autre des recettes
surestimé avec un message clair de la
cour
le prochain président de la république
et sa majorité devront faire les
réformes nécessaires et courageuses que
vous n'avez pas fait
il faudra un effort drastique sur la
dépense publique
ce rapport est emblématique de votre
quinquennat le dérapage est difficile
sans réforme c'est-à-dire un dérapage
pour rien et des milliards de dépenses
pour certaines politiques publiques sans
résultat en fin de mandat monsieur le
premier ministre vous ouvrait les vannes
comme si vous ne vous sentiez
responsable de rien alors que vous êtes
responsable oui responsable de la
situation catastrophique que vous allez
laisser et les français veulent vous
entendre sur ce sujet
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre bernard cazeneuve
monsieur le député vos questions sont
toujours un moment absolument
irremplaçables de délice pour une raison
très simple c'est qu'ils sont une
occasion rare de comparer ce que vous
avez fait avec ce que nous avons fait et
comme vous venez de m'en donner
l'occasion
je vais le faire avec une exigence de
précision que je n'ai trouvé à aucun
moment dans la question que vous venez
de m'adresser premier point il est tout
à fait normal que la cour des comptes
est à l'égard d'un gouvernement des
exigences elle en a toujours eu et ce
dialogue entre eux la cour des comptes
et le gouvernement est consubstantielle
aux missions de la cour des comptes et
il appartient au gouvernement comme il
l'a toujours fait d'apporter des
réponses et je vais répondre à la fois
la cour des comptes et à votre
interrogation
d'abord vous nous donner des leçons de
bonne gestion budgétaire comme si vous
étiez légitime à le faire laissez moi
monsieur le député rappeler un certain
nombre d'éléments objectifs lorsque la
majorité que vous avez soutenu à quitter
le pouvoir le déficit public était de
5,1 pour cent
vous étiez à l'époque en pâmoison de
satisfaction il est aujourd'hui de 3,3
pour cent et le déficit budgétaire
témoigne que nous atteindrons cet
objectif mais ça vous fait de la peine
lorsque nous sommes à 3,3 pour cent de
déficit alors que vous étiez content
lorsque vous étiez à 5,1 pour cent
le déficit budgétaire ayant même dépassé
les 7%
le violoniste l'économie et des finances
si j'ai bonne souvenance en 2010
deuxièmement vous parlez des dépenses
publiques vous avez tout à fait raison
d'en parler
vous les avez augmenté de 170 milliards
lorsque vous étiez en situation de
responsabilité les dépenses publiques
augmenté de 3%
mais à ce moment là vous étiez dans une
situation de satisfaction qui tangente l
apothéose
aujourd'hui nous avons divisé par trois
le rythme d'augmentation de la dépense
publique
nous avons fait en sorte que les
déficits publics soient maîtriser le
déficit de le du régime général de la
sécurité sociale est raide
je versais en monsieur woerth continue
et en convoquant des bobards à longueur
de questions à laisser à penser que soit
vous avez bien géré là où c'est nous qui
avons fait les efforts de rétablissement
des comptes publics
alors vous nous dites oui mais la cour
des comptes à des interrogations pour
mais monsieur le député elle avait
exactement les mêmes interrogations pour
et alors même que nous avons dû pour des
raisons qui tiennent notamment au
terrorisme
augmenter les effectifs des forces de
sécurité faire des efforts
supplémentaires pour leur permettre de
faire face à la situation et assurer la
sécurité des français
on constate en 2016 que les objectifs
que nous nous étions assignés à
nous-mêmes sont à ta ils le seront en
2017 et ils le seront en 2018 grâce à
l'action de michel sapin grâce à
l'action de christian eckert qui ont sur
ces sujets toujours été dans la
transparence et la plus absolue rigueur
alors monsieur le député laissez moi
vous dire les choses avec la plus grande
franchise je préfère vous laisser votre
auto satisfaction
je préfère vous laisser le contentement
que vous avez de vous même lorsque vous
avez laissé exploser la dette de 25
points de pib et nous laisser faire le
travail que nous faisons avec un souci
de transparence et de respect des
français car votre bilan est telle que
vous n'avez pas d'autre solution que de
faire campagne avec des bobards
[Applaudissements]